good morning the chancellor rishi sunak
will hail a new age of optimism when he
delivers his much-trailed budget this
lunchtime is expected to say he has more
to spend as the country's rebounded
better than expected from the pandemic
but critics don't share his vision for a
stronger economy fearing many will be
left just worse off our deputy political
editor sam coats reports
these are the pictures the chancellor
wants you to see of someone keeping a
tight reign on budgets rather than
delivering a sugar rush to the economy
today rishi sunak will say there are
limits to what he can afford new fiscal
rules on the financial help he can offer
but in leicester where over a third of
people live in the most financially
deprived pockets of the country the
demands on the chancellor are limitless
what do you want out of them what do you
want from the government i want better
education and better health service i
think they could spend more on education
because i'm a pgce teacher i'm a
training teacher so i think that it
would definitely be beneficial to put
more money into the education department
i think public transport would be a
really good area to spend more on later
on rishi sunak will deliver his
priorities in a speech to the house of
commons he will say today's budget
begins the work of preparing for a new
economy postcovid an economy of higher
wages higher skills and rising
productivity of strong public services
vibrant communities and safer streets an
economy fit for an age of optimism that
is the stronger economy of the future
stronger for the future but it can't be
strong everywhere
leveling up can't be universal
leveling up boris johnson's promise
turning into rishi sunax nightmare
whether it's funding for skills money
for farmers or dealing with high energy
bills every single cabinet minister now
says their pet demand is part of
leveling up but rishi suna can't afford
it all
business groups accept that premise
every region's going to ask for money
for skills training for incentives uh to
support prosperity and once you multiply
that uh by the different areas of the
united kingdom there's just simply not
enough money for that it wasn't
reinvented the phrase leveling up and
made it central part of the government's
agenda
and
there is a lot that can be done to
better balance the regions of the uk
and this time around let's have
something that means something that's
properly defined and that all regions
including the midlands including the
east midlands get a fair crack at that
this isn't an austerity budget but nor
is there money for tax cuts
the same things that have driven up
tax and spend this year in particular
the need to spend on health and social
care driven in part by an aging
population those things aren't going to
go
away and my guess is that over the next
decade whatever might happen over the
next two or three years the overall
level of taxation will probably continue
to rise
the chancellor will have more money to
play with than many expected
but he wants to be remembered as prudent
not everyone can win
sam coats sky news in leicester
well let's speak to the former treasury
minister and former housing secretary
robert jenner mr generic always great to
see you thanks for joining us on this
budget day who's going to be better off
today
well i think there's an uncertain
picture across the world with inflation
with shortages and
issues that the chancellor have to
contend with but as your report just
said there are reasons for optimism
unemployment in particular is much lower
than people expected and the british
economy is growing it's going to be the
fastest growing of any g7 economy so i
think that does give the chancellor some
room room for two things really firstly
for some more investment in public
services to tackle the cost of living
and a proper plan to grow the economy as
we move forwards but he's going to have
to balance that with the need to be
fiscally responsible because of that
continued uncertainty and i think that's
the backdrop which the chancellor has
been considering in the weeks that have
preceded the budget
so who's going to be better off today
well i think we're we're all going to be
better off in the sense that it looks
like the opr forecasts are going to show
that the economy has grown substantially
therefore we're less we're borrowing
much less money as a country and that
gives some more room for the chancellor
to invest in the future of public
services which we all depend on like the
nhs but i think he's also going to have
to think carefully about those people on
the most modest incomes and how he can
help them to whether what's undoubtedly
still going to be a difficult period
when we're seeing inflation rising
higher energy prices and so on
you've seen that in some of the
announcements that have already been
made like the decision to increase the
national living wage which is going to
lead to an increase in wages for about 2
million people across the country and
the decision to move to a more normal
period for public sector workers as well
so that there won't be a freeze there
but the pay review bodies will be
deciding in the months to come
what's a sensible and affordable
increase in wages for that six million
people right across the country so i
think it's striking that balance
along with as i say continuing to be
fiscally prudent because we just don't
know what the future holds and inflation
means the risk of interest rate rises
okay and that's very costly given that
we're all
the chancellor's books sure given that
we're all going to be better off um
public sector workers are going to get
an above inflation pay rise
well we don't know and we can't say that
yet can we to be fair to the champions
it's got to be higher than inflation
hasn't it
well the way that public sector pay is
set in this country is by pay review
bodies who then advise the relevant
government department through a proper
process and those are independent bodies
that include trade unionists business
people experts as i think what the
chancellor is going to say is that we're
able as a result of the growing economy
to move into a more normal period that
means that he's going to be asking those
pay review bodies to come forward with
their proposals
and then he'll consider those all the
relevant government departments will
consider them next year so i don't think
he'll be in the position to say exactly
uh what you would like him to say just
yet but that's going to be a few months
off um so people just have to wait a bit
longer but yeah i think as a result of
it
has been managed
last year just let me say and you can of
course override those pay review bodies
as we all know if that's what you choose
to do either more in favor of the
workers or less as indeed we saw last
year unless it is above inflation pay
rise you said everybody's going to be
better off unless it's an above impact
inflation pay rise then we're not all
going to be better off are we
well i said that i think there'll be
good news across the ball for the
economy and for members of the public
because we'll be able to invest more in
public services and be more fiscally
prudent so we've got some protection
built into the economy should there be
shocks down the line i think it is good
news given the cost of living challenge
that we have right now that we are going
to be able to increase wages uh either
through the national living wage going
up that's a very significant development
probably the most significant one
because that's going to lead to the
people who are on the lowest wages many
of whom are within the public sector
like care workers for example but others
across the board those people are going
to be seeing a pay rise of around six
and a half percent that's very
significant
increase and really welcome given what's
happening uh for the cost of living we
were all good the public sector is what
you said
i think i think we're just going i think
we're all just going to have to wait and
see what the pay review bodies report
back and there'd be no point
circumventing that process given that
it's been set up in that way
why is the gender pay gap still at seven
point nine percent according to the ons
office for national statistics i mean
that has been illegal since 1970 it's
increased during the pandemic why is
this government still condoning men
being paid more than women
well the government doesn't condone men
being paid
it's been against the law for a very
long time and we've been bearing down
upon it there are structural issues
within the economy about the different
types of jobs that sometimes men and
women do but we as a government have
been trying to tackle this for a long
time it is coming down uh it has been
coming down over the course of the last
10 years but it's still unacceptable
over the last year you and i have gone
up it's gone up over the last year it's
increased to 7.9
well that may be the case over the last
year but the longer term trend is is
downwards uh but i'm not i'm not here to
defend that absolutely not it's
completely wrong we want to see more
women in the workplace and those who've
been properly rewarded for the work that
they do and it's for employers
to make sure that they're doing that
yeah but it's also against the law and
it has been for 50 years so you would
have hoped that perhaps it would have
gone by now but let's wait and see
test and trace has been described by the
pm as world beating a parliamentary
investigation says it's an eye-watering
waste of taxpayers money which is it
well i've seen the reporting on the the
public accounts committee's work this
morning and that's something i'm
certainly going to to read it is very
concerning what they've said on the
other hand it is a program that
i think has led to 320 million tests
being done over the course of the last
year and a year and a bit
20 million people have been contacted so
it has played an important part in
tackling the pandemic are there lessons
that can and must be learned from it i
think absolutely and we're all going to
have to pay particularly the government
to what's said by the public accounts
committee
okay slightly running out of time so i
can't press you further on that but what
i can ask you about is our most
important diplomat uh her majesty she is
not going to be at cop 26. the pm said
to a group of kids in downing street
it's touch and go if cop 26 will be a
success and he is very worried about it
given that her majesty is now also not
going how
much do you think it's going to be a
success or a failure what's the
likelihood
well firstly like you i said my best
wishes to her imagine the queen i know
she would have liked to have been at cop
and she's going to be doing a video
message it's much more important that
she puts her own health and well-being
first
but as regards cop well i i think there
is a lot more work to be done i've seen
alex sharma has been meeting chinese
representatives in the last 24 hours we
need to ensure that those countries who
are the biggest global emitters come to
the table and there will be a lot of
last minute wrangling and negotiation to
be done i don't think the prime minister
or indeed alex sharma could have done
more than they have in terms of trying
to corral global
nations to to take action and there has
been some significant progress in the
last couple of days i think for example
scott morrison in australia making a
significant step to some extent saudi
arabia although it's it's to a slower
trajectory than we would have wanted but
you can see progress but a lot more now
needs to be achieved just in a couple of
days
okay uh finally before i let you go why
are masks mandatory for all staff in the
house of commons contractors press and
third parties but not for mps
i i don't know is the honest answer to
that okay i mean that's a decision i
think by the house authorities or the
speaker who issued those guidelines uh
it doesn't seem right to me that there's
one rule for everyone else who works in
the building but not for members of
parliament so i think we will have to
change our behavior accordingly i wore a
mask when i was voting last night uh
through the pack division lobbies i
think we'll all have to consider wearing
a mask in the coming days
and will you wear one for the budget
i i think i will yeah because it will be
a busy occasion lots of people tightly
packed um i i don't think that as
members of parliament we can ask
something different of our staff and the
people who work in the building then
we're doing ourselves
so generic i'm so sorry i can't talk to
you in person it's always much more fun
doing that forgive me uh for
interrupting you on occasion it's always
a little bit tricky isn't it when it's
down the line it's a pleasure talking to
you we'll see you very soon hopefully
thank you
nice to see you bye now bye now bye-bye
and a reminder we'll have a special live
coverage of the budget here on sky news
and sky news online throughout the day
meantime still to come on the program
for you uh we'll speak to the former
later labour shadow chancellor john
mcdonnell for his views ahead of
chancellor richie sunac's budget
740 joined by royal biographer angela
levin to talk about the queen's absence
from the clock
about that we should 26 had a picture of
the queen there we'll have one next time
i promise and the chancellor
may be feeling positive about his
post-covet economy but not everyone is
we'll discuss the budget fears for those
on universal credit at 7
coronavirus is said to have widened the
divisions between the richest and the
poorest in society and opponents fear
that this budget will do little to help
those struggling to get by
fraser moord joins us now from
manchester where he's at a food bank
this morning hi uh fraser more and more
needed uh the food banks up and down the
country
absolutely and they're having more and
more trouble getting hold of the food
that they need to distribute uh here at
this food bank run by rainbow surprising
council in north manchester we can see
it looks as though they do have some
stock in here at the moment it's a
fantastic community project this is a
community shop as well as being a food
bank there's a children's play group as
well where free meals will be given out
later on today and there are other
community projects here as well the
chair is shakka is saying just how tough
is it at the moment are you seeing more
and more people coming in and having to
use the food bank facilities yes again
for the last four weeks we've seen a
dramatic increase on the families that
are being referred whether they're
self-referring themselves or through the
councils or through professionals like
social workers and gps however we've
seen a lot of increase in the
self-referral because
the families have with this
loss of the universal credit 20 pound
that was temporarily out that's making a
big difference and an impact and it's
not just the people on benefits is
people who are working classes well
that's really finding it difficult at
the moment have you noticed a rise in
the number of people because of the
increase in fuel costs so far they
started to bite yet that is definitely
had uh definitely had a part to play in
it i mean everything makes a big
difference even if a few pennies
increased these days because what we've
gone through in the last two years
everybody in this country everybody's
seen such a massive difference in the
finances
and they have to it's penny pinching
just one last thing what would you like
to hear from the chancellor today to
help the people
who have to come in here yeah well i
would like to see a lot of difference
made towards the working class and
helping people towards the benefits as
well making doing something that's going
to make their life easier and let them
get back on track so they're not
depending on people like ourselves and
the food banks
and they can make their own life better
okay thanks very much for talking to us
today another issue that they're having
here is actually getting the supplies in
there are shortages on the shelves of
the supermarkets that means that there
are shortages of any excess food that
can be donated to places like this so
it's building into a bit of a perfect
storm for the food banks okay fergus
thank you
concerns the queen's absence from the
cop 26 climate summit in glasgow next
week might persuade some world leaders
to stay at home the queen has pulled out
on medical advice to rest and will
deliver a recorded address to the
delegates instead so what is going on
our royal correspondent random mills is
with us now hello to you um rihannon um
is she poorly
so this is a decision that will not have
been taken lightly literally for weeks
we've been talking about the fact that
queen was going to host this reception
and it's been widely wanted to be known
that she'd be there to welcome the world
leaders
so her pulling out really i think has
come down to doctor's orders i think
they have decided that that long journey
from windsor to glasgow was simply too
much now inevitably it is going to cause
concern this is now the second big
engagement that she's pulled out of
in a week and that is incredibly rare
during her reign but she is 95 years old
october has been an incredibly busy
month one thing she's been doing
throughout october is talking about cop
so i think that shows just how much she
wanted to go it has made me think about
prince philip when he was in his mid-90s
he was able to retire from public life
to step back because he was fed up with
all those questions about his health for
the queen though that simply is not an
option because she wants to be
seen to be so heavily involved still
in all of those constitutional duties
the palace stock phrase at the moment is
that she is in good spirits that she's
still carrying out those light duties
and they would have been really keen to
get those pictures out yesterday of her
welcoming two new ambassadors to the uk
also as you mentioned there she is still
going to record a message that will be
played at that reception where we
understand she's going to stress how she
wants to see meaningful actions take
place at the climate summit other
members of the family of course are also
going to go but there's no doubt her
influence is going to be missed and we
also understand that the queen herself
is very keen that other world leaders do
not just use her absence as an excuse
not to turn up
okay thank you
what's thought to be the final image of
the camera operator helena hutchins on
the set of the film rust has been shared
on social media it shows us standing in
front of alec baldwin before the actor
accidentally shot and killed her the
district attorney is reported to have
said the firearm used was a legitimate
gun and not a prop our u.s correspondent
greg milam is in santa fe in new mexico
well we will hear from the sheriff and
the district attorney here later today
in their first news conference actually
since that incident happened
last thursday we have had quite a lot of
information
uh from the police by way of an
affidavit that they filed to a judge to
get a search warrant uh containing a lot
of information from those who were there
on set describing what happened uh
describing alec baldwin as it was
described
cross-drawing his weapon to point it
towards the camera during a rehearsal
and it was then that that weapon was
discharged and we know the
cinematographer helena hutchins was was
shot and killed in fact what's purported
to be the last image of her on set has
been released by
someone who was working on that on that
film
we know also from the district attorney
who last week said that it was hard to
say whether there would be any criminal
charges as a result of that incident
has now told the new york times
that everything is on the table
including uh criminal charges she said
that the focus is on the ballistic
evidence trying to establish what it was
the projectile that was in that weapon
and how it got there and she said an
enormous amount of ammunition
had been recovered from the scene not
clear what type of ammunition
that was and she also said that this
this idea that it was a prop gun which
it was somehow mischaracterizes um the
weapon involved it was a real gun as as
most prop guns are
an antique era weapon as she described
it but but a real gun she also said it
would it would be weeks possibly months
before any decision would be reached on
whether anyone would be charged as a
result of of what happened so there are
all these questions uh suggestions that
maybe these weapons were used for target
practice uh during breaks in in in
filming and a real quest for answers uh
coming of course around the
investigation but also from the wider
entertainment industry but this
investigation is clear will take some
time
returning now to our top story and today
is not just a budget but also a spending
review when the chancellor announces
which departments get what in terms of
cash our economics and data editor that
said conway of course has been looking
at how much the chancellor has to spend
can it be that time of year again yes it
is budget time and indeed this time we
get the spending review as well i'm
going to tell you the things to look out
for there are three of them three
headlines here first of all we get new
economic forecasts and perhaps most
important of all though inflation's
really important this time around as
well it's gross domestic products so the
the size of the economy and you can see
just over the course of the last few
years the financial crisis there a bit
of a dip that went up up up and around
2020 early 2020 the expectation was it
was going to go even higher that dotted
line there but of course we all know
what happened next don't we look a
massive fall when covert hit lockdowns
hit and it went down there last time the
obr the office budget responsibility
looked at this it thought we would have
a bit of a dip and that red line it
would go higher and higher in the next
few years but what we do know is
actually things have come in a bit
better than expected look at that white
line a bit steeper in the recovery so we
might get an upgrade on economic growth
so that's good news for us and indeed
for the chancellor also second thing
taxes we get new tax policy potentially
but there's been an awful lot happening
this year already this is showing you
the tax burden so just the total amount
of tax as a percentage of national
income in the uk and it goes all the way
over to 1955. but have a look at this we
with those national insurance increases
with corporation tax increases we've got
all of that this year massive tax
increases as a result of that the dotted
line doesn't look like it's that high
does it but actually that's now at the
highest sustained level ever so we'll
get new tax policy from the chancellor
and the question is whether it moves
that needle finally and this is unusual
we get a spending review a three-year
spending review the government's setting
out what it's spending there's been so
many numbers on this recently haven't
there so many press releases so many
announcements let's just focus on what's
actually going on here the government
spends about just over a trillion pounds
in total but you can break that down you
can break it down in two ways annually
managed expenditure and departmental
spending the blue stuff and the red
stuff the blue stuff and in the
management expenditure that's the stuff
the government doesn't really control on
an annual basis stuff like debt interest
welfare pensions things like that
what we're really focused on here is the
red stuff departmental spending what is
spending on day-to-day spending and
investment in all of those different
departments so let's take those two bars
and focus on them in particular look you
can see this is much higher day-to-day
spending then you've got capital that's
you know all the spending on investments
on big projects we know they're going to
go a bit higher in their spending
reviews so up to 441 113 but the
interesting thing is if we take this in
particular day-to-day spending move it
across here what we're really focusing
on here what really matters when you
pull away everything else is the extra
bit 56 billion pounds of extra spending
and we already know some of that's going
to the nh that's about 14 billion pounds
we had that earlier on this year we know
some
is likely to go to schools and aid maybe
about 6 billion pounds which leaves
roughly 36 billion pounds that really is
what this spending review is about who
is going to get that money how is the
economy going to do what's going to
happen to taxes all sorts of things that
are going to be decided in this budget
and spending review it could be a very
big day
36 billion pounds isn't that how much
the test and trace scheme cost
asking for a friend more of the day's
news final prince andrew's lawyer has
asked a new york judge not to reveal the
details of a private document which he
believes will protect the prince in his
upcoming lawsuit he's facing claims that
he assaulted virginia dufrey when she
was just 17 which he denies his lawyer
believes the document will release him
from any liability and he intends to use
them to try to get the lawsuit dismissed
gloucestershire police has been graded
as inadequate in half of its 10 key
performance indicators including
safeguarding vulnerable victims a recent
inspection found domestic abuse crimes
were of particular concern the force
says it accepts there's much work still
to be done
more than 80 000 children aged between
12 and 15 have been booked in online to
receive their covid19 vaccinations two
and a half million letters have now been
sent out inviting parents to book a jab
for their child this half term through
the national booking service
looking at the weather for you next few
days looking mild and windy with rain in
parts of the north and west bringing the
risk of local flooding
at least two people have died in strong
storms battering the italian island of
sicily powerful storm hit the island
yesterday causing widespread flooding
around the city of catania the mayor has
urged residents to stay indoors for
safety reasons following a surge in
requests for help reaching local
authorities meteorologists in italy
expect the storm to peak
between now and friday
coming up the former labour shadow
chancellor john mcdonald gives us his
views ahead of the budget that's come
[Music]
[Music]
they say they can't go back to myanmar
yet if they do they fear they'll be
killed
[Applause]
[Music]
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
if there is a bigger explosion this area
would be in the danger zone
[Music]
these traffic jams snake for hours up
and down this hillside it means pressure
day can't access those and needs
you can see the depth of water if you
have a look in front of us there are
people wading through it
[Music]
i think experiencing the two million
person march in hong kong
that was a moment
i don't like the chinese government it's
true
[Music]
it was real people power in action
police have been firing tear gas and
rubber balloons
see fires all around us here and just
one of them is the size of around 31 000
football pitches siobhan robbins sky
news bangkok
[Applause]
[Music]
the former treasury minister um
robert genwick says the chancellor will
have to help those on low incomes
through the winter in today's budget
rishi sunak is believed to have more to
spend as the country's rebounded better
than expected from the pandemic but mr
generic wants help for everybody
well i think we're we're all going to be
better off in the sense that it looks
like the opr forecasts are going to show
that the economy has grown substantially
therefore we're less we're borrowing
much less money as a country and that
gives some more room for the chancellor
to invest in the future of public
services which we all depend on like the
nhs but i think he's also going to have
to think carefully about those people on
the most modest incomes and how he can
help them to whether what's undoubtedly
still going to be a difficult period
when we're seeing inflation rising
higher energy prices and so on
he went on to say that we're all going
to be better off as a result tomorrow's
here um as a result of the uh budget uh
but didn't ex explain how that's right
the chancellor chance's challenge was
set out there by robert generic he's
trying to ride two horses here
essentially he's trying to say there's
some economic good news as mr generic
said the forecasts are looking a lot
better that's tens of billions of pounds
extra to play with and what he's saying
is that a lot of that is going to go
into public services we've heard many of
the announcements already billions of
pounds for the nhs and a pay increase
for the on the minimum wage and for the
public sector coming in next year so
lots of economic good news the
chancellor will say he'll say we're
going to the post-covet age he certainly
hopes so but then he's also trying to
appear fiscally prudent as the
chancellor who was the face of the
furlough scheme and all the covered
schemes to help people get through the
pandemic he's now trying to reinvent
himself as the chancellor who's
controlling the public finances and
that's a difficult message because on
something like universal credit he's
saying we just don't have the money to
carry on giving people that extra 20
pounds a week and what will be causing
jitters for many tory mps in marginal
seats is are people going to feel the
impact of this good news in the coming
months because those pay rises whatever
they turn out to be won't be clear until
next april we've also got of course a
specter of rising inflation which is
going to make things in the shops going
to make fuel bills much more expensive
and so if people aren't seen over the
coming months to feel any better off or
a deal indeed feel a lot worse off then
this won't be seen as a great success
yeah i did ask him about um
pay for men and women still not being on
level playing fields couldn't really say
that much about that but i was
interested here what he said about masks
that's right yesterday new guidance was
issued about masks so that everyone in
parliament that's all staff
have to wear masks indoors which hasn't
been happening that consistently but the
house of commons can't tell mps what to
do on that they they're responsible for
themselves and it was interesting to
hear robert generick saying he will be
wearing a mask in the pact chamber today
and it's time for mps he said to change
their behavior so we've traditionally
seen a lot more masks on the labour
benches than the tory ones i wonder if
we will be seeing more tories wearing
masks today in the light of rising case
numbers and the idea that they need to
be setting an example to the public i do
so in fact went further lydia and said
that uh the rules should change so it's
the same for everybody you're um
hightailing it to downey street i will
see you there okay looking forward to it
thanks very much indeed in the meantime
let's bring in the former labour shadow
chancellor john mcdonald who is joining
us now what does a former labour shadow
chancellor do when it's budget day these
days um appear on came early in the
morning i suppose um
comment comment basically about the
the the budget itself what's in what's
in it and what should be in it and
provided advice as much as possible but
also
to work with those who are campaigning
on some of the issues where
more money needs to be spent and the
chancellor the issues that the
chancellor should be addressing
okay are you disappointed that your
party is only calling for uh 10 pounds
an hour minimum wage the tories have
pledged that they'll get to that by the
next election anyway well what's
interesting if we'd have been elected if
you remember kay you interviewed me at
the time it would have been elected in
2019 that 10 pounds an hour would have
been in place by the following april
and because it hasn't been people have
lost out on two and a half thousand
pounds a year so i think what we need is
a but we should have had 10 pounds an
hour in place anyway and then we should
work towards something higher people
have argued and people are negotiating
now around 15 pounds an hour i think we
should give that commitment that by the
next election that's what we should be
moving to because
people out there are suffering you know
the chancellor has put out this slogan
today about
optimism well i don't think people who
have just had their universal credit cut
are going to feel particularly
optimistic with inflation rising energy
prices rising and you know even that
announcement on lifting the pay freeze
was spoiled when they said well actually
we're lifting the pay freeze but you're
not guaranteed that you'll get even a
pay rise in in line with inflation or
that will provide the money to those
local authorities or public services to
pay for the pay freeze so i this idea
that suddenly you can bring about
optimism when you're disappointing so
many people
i think is going to come back and the
chancellor is going to have to think
again i'm hoping today one example i'm
hoping today he reverses universal
credit card but also he guarantees
public sector workers a real pay rise so
above the rate of inflation
you know neither of those are going to
happen though uh former shadow
chancellor don't you because i did put
that to uh one of his ministers uh
yesterday he basically said that's not
going to happen at least for now they
would also say that they need to wait
for the pay review bodies to give them
guidance as to how much
public sector pay workers should get
gone
i think he's under a lot of pressure on
the universal credit issue so i wouldn't
be surprised if there is some movement
there maybe around you know the taper
how much you take away from people and i
think the build-up on if he doesn't do
something on pay today i think he's
going to have to be forced into it in
the coming months if you look at what's
happening from the trade union movement
at the moment they're basically a number
of the trade unions are now balloting
their members for industrial action why
not because they want to strike or
dispute it's because their members are
saying we can't live off the wages that
we now have they've been frozen for over
a decade the tuc figures yesterday
revealed that actually there's a naught
percent rise a froze freezing pay since
2011.
so people just literally can't get by
and i think i think he's going to have
to shift on pay at some stage as well as
i do
chancellor that he's come up with an
extra more than 500 million pounds for
those who
sadly are no longer getting that uh 20
pounds uplift on universal credit but if
they do need more money there's he's
found 500 million quid to help those
people
well he should come out now today and
say i'm not going ahead with universal
credit the obr figures mean we've got a
little bit more to just play with why
don't we actually spend that on the most
needy if he did that i think he'd be
welcomed on all sides of the house
including large numbers of his own
conservative mps who are reporting back
to him from their constituencies some of
the new mps in those supposed red wall
seats say people can't live off what
they have at the moment and there's real
poverty and suffering out there don't
hit the poorest when you're making these
sorts of cuts and so i think the
pressure will be upon him to move in
some form we might see something today
but if not i think we'll see it
eventually
okay former shadow chancellor thank you
very much indeed for joining us we
appreciate it thank you good to see you
you too
now the queen's not going to the cop 26
climate change conference and there are
concerns that may put off other world
leaders from attending uh joining us is
journalist and royal biographer angela
levin hello to you andrew it's always
great thanks for joining us on the
programme this morning you know she is
our best known uh leading diplomat
if she's not there what impact will it
have on a conference like cop well you
know a lot of people do come to gladhand
with the queen
yes absolutely i mean fortunately she is
going to pre-record
um
comments which will be heard over there
and and the way she does this is
absolutely brilliant isn't it she always
wins people round millions want to
listen to what she says she's so
succinct and common sense and
i think that that is some sort of small
compensation but otherwise i think
people will be very disappointed because
as you're showing now on the screen that
people came from all around
last week
to just see her smile and look where
they're looking at her with a grin
because they just think she's the most
extraordinary woman and she is she's
probably one of the most popular in the
world and makes the british monarchy
accessible to people who who just think
she's terrific
do you think it's just precautionary um
i suppose some people more concerned
because the palace chose uh to keep
secret that she spent a night in
hospital a couple events now being
cancelled
yes i i think two things i think the
journey back and forth
to glasgow and to then work very hard
and go around bland handing everybody is
very tiring
um you've got to be in good condition
and at the top of your
you know as much as you can really and
and i think it could possibly be just
too much for her i think perhaps she
recognized yesterday
that um even doing um
meeting the ambassador of switzerland
and the ambassador of korea was really
quite a lot and i think she's being very
sensible the other thing is which is
very important is that elderly people
don't recover from even tiredness or any
sort of ill health quickly young people
can push it off uh because the
antibodies are up and lively and
and fighting but i think when you're
much older we have to keep saying to
ourselves she is 95 but it takes much
longer to overcome fatigue and for the
body to be back up to you know
reasonable behavior and i think that
that counts as well and she doesn't want
to undermine what she's done which is
not take the dogs out for a week for a
walk which is very rare for her and to
build up her strength slowly and
gradually so that she can come back and
do
lighter things and not so many of them
for us
yeah she must be very um
tired if she's not taking the dogs out i
mean her raise on detroit on many
occasions in the past as we know is this
though you know looking forward is this
a water will we see this as a watershed
moment for the royal family the others
like charles and camilla and william and
kate they seem to be circling the wagons
now
yes i think it is sometimes these small
things and i think it was her
having a walking stick it seems quite a
small thing you know you can say so what
because it was cobblestones to get to
westminster abbey but actually i think
these are very significant and things
can change enormously i think people are
not going to put pressure on her to do
as many engagements as she would like i
think they will ease right off her so
they should and she's also not going to
go anywhere without one of the senior
royals being with her so she doesn't
feel very well somebody can do it she
doesn't have to let people down and i
think this will make her feel more
relaxed and will work um very well
what's very nice is we hear so much
criticism of the royal family how
they're not friendly and they fight and
they don't like each other but here we
see them actually being
like any good family should be you know
come up to it help out your your mother
or your grandmother because although
she's a superwoman she's not going to be
a superwoman forever and and this will
help her continue and feel secure and
loved by her family which i think is um
a wonderful thing for her
yeah good to see you as always angela
thank you very much for joining us thank
you
thank you thank you
nhs test and trace program failed to
stop the spread of covid19 despite being
handed eye-watering sums of money
despite being uh given 37 billion pounds
a new report by mps says it failed in
its aim to give people a return to a
more normal way of life here's melano
vesselnovich with more
it was one of the most expensive health
programs of the pandemic with a budget
of 37 billion pounds over two years but
according to a new report by the public
accounts committee nhs test and trace
failed in its core task
test and trace promised boldly that it
would be the vehicle for preventing
future lockdowns on that it failed
palpably because there were two further
lockdowns but ultimately test and trace
cost a lot said it would deliver things
it didn't deliver on those things so in
its own terms it failed
the report says the system struggled to
deliver tests when under pressure and
called it muddled overstated and
eye-wateringly expensive
the committee criticized the use of
contractors who were paid on average
more than a thousand pounds a day and
this the report says is likely to have
cost taxpayers hundreds of millions of
pounds
some test center workers say their sites
were mismanaged
when i started there the site was open
12 hours a day
then
as we went further down uh
you know
the company or whomever decided that it
would have to be 14 hours a day which by
the nature of the employment contracts
and the way the nhs employs their staff
working times directives etc they
would have to have two teams
they would then have to have those two
teams overlapping which meant that we
basically had twice as many staff as was
necessary to run the site
in a statement the department of health
and social care said to date over
323 million tests have been delivered
and almost 20 million people contacted
who could otherwise have unknowingly
transmitted the virus we have rightly
drawn on the extensive expertise of a
number of public and private sector
partners who have been invaluable in
helping us tackle the virus
but some scientists think contact
tracing failed because isolation wasn't
properly supported
we knew for this system to be successful
it had to meet certain criteria in that
we had to identify
a high percentage of the contacts
probably over 75 percent
and we had to get them to isolate really
within about 48 hours of the contact
and it became very apparent over the
summer in the autumn last year that we
weren't getting anywhere near that
number of cases to isolate
a huge amount of money spent but this
report says there isn't much to show for
it
milenavocillinovic sky news
coming out why not everyone's feeling
optimistic about the budget coming up
we'll discuss the concerns for those on
universal credit
[Music]
climate life started in spring 2019
um after i'd been organizing the youth
climate strikes for a while and realized
that obviously they've been incredible
at mobilizing young people
for climate action but there's also a
lot of young people that aren't engaged
so i thought music would be a really
good way
to engage them um so it started kind of
messaging people within our
international fridays at future network
saying hey shall we do concerts what do
people think about this people said yes
and then that's how climate life was
born as you mentioned we recently held
our events in over 20 countries
our aim is to engage in the audience in
the climate movement by harnessing the
power of music
once they're there educate them
especially focusing on
um the challenges faced by those on the
front lines of the climate crisis
something that's really easy to forget
we've had you know amazing artists all
over the world from colombia to brazil
to the philippines
and as well as artists there's been
speakers so it's kind of combining that
and you know getting people's favorite
artists there and then once
once people are there because of the
artist they then listen to the speakers
and hear about the messaging and join
the movement at such a crucial time
right before the cop 26 conference it's
aimed at world leaders so we've been
young people for the past two three
years have been taking to the streets
and saying you know listen to the
science this is a climate crisis this is
happening there are people on the front
lines being affected right now and
nothing's being done there's lots of
empty promises there's lots of you know
2030
when actually according to the science
that's far too late um
and
yeah we're just saying we are the youth
this is our future and our present and
you're not listening um so we're making
a bit more noise ahead of the conference
and saying you know listen to us listen
to the science can you hear us yeah and
i think it's really good for people to
see that the youth climate movement
isn't all serious
um we're not
um
you know super intense all the time we
do have fun we are young people at the
end of the day
um and yeah other young people should
join us because it's not all it's not
all serious it's not all speeches it's
not all meetings we do actually have fun
and dance around
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
did you know that if we all work
together we can really make a difference
to the air pollution around our schools
yeah we should really do that
wednesday will start mild windy and dry
for many but ireland northern ireland
southern scotland and cumbria will see
rain heavy on the hills there'll be
little change through the morning but
western parts of ireland should dry up
the best of the sunshine will be across
northern scotland it'll stay very mild
and windy
during the afternoon the rain will
largely clear into northwest england and
northwest wales the unsettled conditions
mean air pollution levels are expected
to remain low with the levels between 1
and 3 on the daily air quality index
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
going to be hearing from the chancellor
budget day today after prime minister's
questions is expected to speak of a new
age of optimism but not everyone is
feeling quite so hopeful i suppose let's
find out should we rebecca is with us
she is a single mom on universal credit
hello to you rebecca thanks for joining
us i'm speaking to a government minister
or former minister earlier on in this
hour and he said everybody's going to be
better off after the budget do you feel
that you will be
um
no i'm quite worried about it i mean
obviously
i've seen bits and pieces that say maybe
there's gonna be a pay increase to like
nine pounds fifty and my first thought
about per hour and my first thought
about that was you know yay that's only
fifty pence less than what most people
say is a sensible living wage of ten
pounds
and then i heard you before talking to
someone and they mentioned the tape rate
that's a really big concern because
um you know all the money that i earn
um anything over 290 a month um that's
going to be taken back at the rate of 63
p to every pound so i'm
i'm a bit concerned it seems to me like
it's the classic the government has
taken away
a huge thing like a huge support and now
they're trying to give back a little bit
and pretend that it's a lot
yeah but the government would say in
response to that we never were planning
to keep give you that 20 pounds
forever it was only to get you over um
the pandemic
yes and and i i value that i value that
at the very beginning they said we're
only going to make this temper temporary
but um i guess my response to that would
be if you put in praise a temporary
measure and see that it makes um a
humongous difference to thousands and
millions of vulnerable families across
the country um would you not consider
that perhaps um you should continue with
it or put something in place that's even
better because obviously that was sorely
needed
which that 20 pound was sorely needed
but who should pay for that rebecca
um that i'm not too sure
uh because i don't i don't understand
how
i i'm not rishi sunak that's sort of his
job but um i think that the sensible way
to do it would be to find some way maybe
of um
taxing the more wealthy instead of
penalizing the poorer but i i can't give
you a sensible answer on that because i
i don't i'm not reese's i can't i can't
juggle the country's finances
um yeah indeed apparently it would cost
something like six billion pounds to
keep that in place i suppose what you're
saying in response to that is um it will
cost more uh than that for this there's
so many people who are going to be
struggling on the bread line as a result
of not having that money so the
psychological impact on people who can't
put food on the table is worth 6 billion
yeah exactly that you know you've got to
think of the psychological um issues the
health issues you know that means that
uh millions of people can have to be
eating poorer sort of more processed
food
or you know like just poor quality food
so then that their health is declining
and then it's things like um
other associated health things so you
know example um just catching the bus
places costs quite a bit of a chunk of
money and so then maybe more walking
which is good but also that's cold and
wet so i i you know i don't know if it's
making sense but
i think giving people support and
benefit um
so they can buy healthier food so they
can heat the house so they can afford
the bus
is definitely worth 6 billion or more
i understand you're saying that that
safety net needs to be in place for
families like yours rebecca thank you
very much indeed for joining us on the
program this morning thank you we'll be
hearing uh from rishi sunak just after
12 30 today ready to deliver his next
budget we'll have all the latest news
and analysis on that in just a moment
images of him ahead of the budget we'll
see him at number 11 with his red box a
little bit later on stay tuned
[Music]